can we geek out for one second you got
Carol Burnett and Julie Andrews Susan
Lucci
out of here I can't contain myself what
does it mean to be here to honor Miss
Carol Burnett she deserves it
um she's given us so much she's given me
personally a friendship and mentorship
and she loves he she loves me and I love
her I mean it sounds weird
you you know what I could see the
influence directly I mean think about
how you guys have worked across film TV
and theater have you asked her like
what's the secret to her longevity yes I
have many times and it's never changed
stay in the moment I'm like oh the Oprah
thing saying that she goes and stay in
the Moment On Stage stay in the moment
in a movie stay in the moment and as a
friend it's a great piece of advice that
works for all of it well how cool is
this you get to share this moment with
your cute fiance over there
Joshua over here I have to say you guys
make quite you guys make quite the cute
couple and by the way did you hear this
gentleman he was like I'm gonna stand on
this side so I'm not blocking the hair I
mean you are the one
exactly all right how's wedding planning
going oh it's going
is it stressful
candy yeah yeah I have a really big
family yes and I you know my family's
small
people say tell us to just do family
we're like it's still going to be big it
should be I mean this is your day right
you want to share with all the people
you love definitely we're excited now
Josh you have a say are you kind of Lane
Kristen just planned this thing no it's
a team it is yeah we like I'm doing the
music like because I'm all into that so
yeah yeah they're gonna be some
performances at this wedding you know
yeah a lot of our friends sing and play
it's only a big jam session I think
we're not having live music we're just
gonna all Jam around we don't need a DJ
we are the DJ yeah exactly maybe a
couple instruments and then you got you
right we call them in the South poot
nannies we're gonna have one big hooters
song some way
Over the Rainbow
I know Wicked is obviously filming in
London right now are we getting closer
to you making the cameo in this film or
what cannot confirm or deny I really I
really cannot I believe that yeah I'm
waiting and we'll see but if not I'm
gonna get to watch two women I know soar
and that Ariana Grande is gonna step so
beautifully into my shoes I'm so excited
for her it's the next generation is
she's gonna put her own stamp on it this
Legacy continues and it's going to go on
what right Carol can we get a little ear
Tug come on
oh I heard you're coming back to
Broadway I'm coming back in a musical
called Queen of Versailles it is based
on the documentary The Queen of
Versailles and Stephen Schwartz of
wicked is writing the music and I'm also
a producer
so I've got a big head I've got a big a
lot of work but fun challenging work
ahead of me I gotta tell you we missed
you on the great white way so this is
exciting thank you I'm coming back
[Music]